since I was six I wanted to be a [ __ ]
wrestler the Hardy Boys was [ __ ]
amazing x-pac was like my idol so
performance is always one to make it
feel like it was the WWF or some [ __ ]
you know raging and you know having fun
and expressing good feelings is
something up I plan on just like doing
and spreading across the globe
I just need air and a mic yeah I don't
need a I don't need a stage no um we
just need something to stand on it can
be somebody kind of eyes need a platform
you don't you don't like these you don't
like people I just stand you know
whether you're black white brown green
purple yellow blue
you don't want you to stand it around
like this is a nose stands though even
if the DJ don't know you're not you give
that DJ to look like the [ __ ] is
talking okay you find anything you're
going to use to consume to get you like
lit anything even use that's gonna get
you just like ready to go where this
year your drugs your water or where's
your orange juice and your alcohol do
whatever you want to do man like get it
in and you just have fun we with Travis
or if you're Reggie of a savior not with
me okay I feel like deleted rattle okay
just for this night you can get it back
in the morning because I love it over
but tonight you're spinning tonight
wherever you need to start bringing back
camping you know and [ __ ] when people go
out there is no going home
and it's like we're going to spend the
night in the inn we're gonna party all
the way to the [ __ ] Sun goes up right
you put yourself on in your pocket
because there's no snap you can get a
lot you one picture
[ __ ] it I'll give you one pigs you need
one memory cuz at the end i you should
have been [ __ ] throwing up i'm a
cousin definitely to slow motion to do a
motion typically